so
um let's talk about refactoring
um so my name is Kevin Henny and
um
I've been around a while
I remember when the first computers were
created no sorry that's not that old
that's actually
um uh brexit technology it's one of
Britain's uh great exports um you know
we don't need everybody else's silicon
and we can do our own
um
now normally
we associate refactoring
with
dealing with Legacy
this is one of my favorite Legacy
systems
uh
we're not entirely sure what it does
we don't know who built it we don't know
why
but it seems to work twice a year
and you're not allowed to touch her
um
I took this photograph
almost exactly five years ago yeah yeah
Valentine's Day because I'm an incurable
romantic
um took my wife down to see that there's
even a crow perched on one of the
trilothons
and that kind of is the harbinger of of
death and foreboding that's the
experience many people have when they
look at code most people work on
yesterday's code all this talk about
technology being tomorrow is nonsense
most people spend their life living in
the past
if you are spending eight hours on a
code base approximately seven hours
as a typical maximum was spent in the
past dealing with the issues of the past
if you're really lucky one hour is spent
on the future on the other hand that
might just be uh complaining about the
code base to a colleague by the coffee
machine
but in many people's minds
they associate refactoring as a kind of
response to Legacy in other people's
minds they associate refactoring as just
a shortcut key
okay it's the hence the clickbait title
A lot of people oh yeah refactoring it's
on my context menu yeah I know the
shortcut for rename
and that's kind of it
but we need to go a little bit further
than this I mean where does a lot of
this stuff come from where does a lot of
our response and actually I'm going to
say some of our response is not entirely
accurate
and our perceptions where does it come
from
so wonderful quote from Neil Ford the
developers are drawn to complexity like
Master to a flame often with the same
outcome
there is this sense that sometimes we
create our own complexity human mind is
a wonderful thing
um
we're very good at speculating it's a
form of imagination
we imagine how a system might be
the problem is not that we use
our imagination it's not that we are
able to speculate it's that we then go
and put it in the code
I wonder if oh yeah somebody might do
this quick accommodate that with an
extra kind of hook or an extra work
around or an attribute or something
that'll make it easier to develop in
future guess what the future arrives and
you're in that seven hours
going
what the actual
this is stupid the Futures arrived it
looks like nothing like this but I still
have to bear the weight of all those
decisions in the past that we're
supposed to make the future easier
we are very good at taking simple things
and making them complex we're also very
good at taking things that are
sophisticated and making them simplistic
causing exactly the same problem yeah
and a lot of people
then attribute this to technical debt
they describe it as technical debt now
it's not that it isn't a technical debt
but there are two issues here
first of all technical debt is not
necessarily a bad thing when sometimes
when people tell me they say oh okay our
code base has lots of technical debt
right but what are you trying to say are
you trying to say it's a good thing or a
bad thing now whenever I do stuff like
that people
they well they actually what I hope they
think is wow Kevin's challenging my
perception what they actually think is
Kevin's an idiot doesn't he know about
technical debt well I do know about
technical debt
um
we're now at a point where it's over 30
years old as an idea Ward Cunningham
developed it in 92. specifically though
he didn't call it technical there he
called it debt the term technical debt
was not truly cemented in place till the
early 2000s at the end of the 1990s I
was using the term occasionally
technical debt but I didn't like it I
prefer quality debt or design debt
design deck was my favorite
but as of the early 2000s we cemented it
in to mean we use the term technical
debt
but
the reason I challenge this is that Ward
did not originally say debt is a bad
thing he just said debt is a thing and
you can it can be bad but you can also
use debt constructively in fact the
reason he introduced it as a metaphor
was to use it constructively we've ended
up using it only destructively we use
debt for a number of things I can run up
a debt short term in order to achieve a
benefit that I might not otherwise have
been able to achieve I can even do this
long term and have a structured
repayment so my wife and I had a
mortgage That's a classic example of a
debt it's a very long-term thing what's
the benefit you get a house
but I don't wait for people with
um baseball bats to come around to
collect money we have a structured
repayment model debt is not
intrinsically bad debt is a thing the
question is what you do next as to
whether or not it's good or bad so when
people tell me we have lots of technical
debt they're not actually telling me
what they want to tell me
so technical debt is an observation you
can make on a system of people and
Technology
and you can make a value judgment about
it but what most people are ignoring
is how did you get it it's technical
debt's not a process it's an outcome
there is a process which I started to
call technical neglect
because people keep being distracted oh
we've got technical debt what do we do
about it
do you have unmanaged technical debt yes
that's what we said well you should say
it it's unmanaged technical debt that's
your problem
how did you get it we have no idea
it just appeared like the bugs
but until you understand that you need
to understand that it is the act of a
thousand edits it doesn't happen just
once technical debt is just not
mysteriously appear overnight
oh look I suddenly got a mortgage I
hadn't planned on that
yeah banks are a little more cautious
about things like that
it's more a case of
these are small debts they're your
little credit card things I'll just
charge that I'll just charge this I'll
just do that oh a snack here a snack
there shortcut here a shortcut there
yeah I know there's a better way of
doing this and
a thousand edits later you're going like
oh
where did this come from
and unfortunately it's got interest it's
got your interest it's got
percentage-wise interest
but you need to look at the process
neglect
as we have physical neglect we have
emotional neglect these are Concepts
that are known in the world we should
also look at the idea of technical
neglect
and then in response to this we often
position refactory so if you've not come
across commit strip you need to come
across commit strip there you go that
was easy
um
got a project manager talking to a
developer here
so will the refactoring and will
refactoring code improve the loading
time not really
well it improve security then nope so
it's for browser compatibility oh
absolutely not
so tell me why is it always the same old
story with you guys wanted to refactor
everything I need to know
because it's Debs if we know we've left
messy Co we can't stop thinking about it
when we wake up in the morning at
lunchtime in the evening when we go home
and when we're trying to go to sleep and
for those of you
who were awake at three o'clock in the
morning every now and then then as well
it haunts us you know it haunts us
can make it a little bit better now I
think at this point we need to recognize
that
software development is a
knowledge-based endeavor
what you're doing with a code base is
you are codifying quite literally
codifying knowledge your knowledge of
the domain knowledge of the Technologies
knowledge of how you work with the tools
it's literally codified so in other
words it's a collaborative effort saying
here's our best shot
now when you put it like that it's just
like well here's a shot
the problem is
here is our knowledge
here is the point at which it was
codified it's always behind we're always
living in the past now we'd like that
tail to be a little bit shorter we'd
like our current thinking as reflected
in our system
to be as close as possible to our
current thinking on our wetware we want
to reduce the distance there's nothing
more frustrating for many people they
experience this it's not
whether or not a code base is Pleasant
to work in
it's whether or not you know how it
could be versus how it is it's the
difference
okay and it's often been said that
comparison is the thief of joy and you
should never compare yourself to others
but when you're dealing with abstract
entities I know that this code could be
better and not just a bit tidier
sometimes you might be looking at a
system
I've had this experience often in our
visiting companies where you're looking
at it and you're going like well this
code base could be about five to ten
percent of its current size five to ten
percent of the current size of a code
base is a a huge step change in quality
of life and quality of delivery it's not
a slight Improvement it is a
fundamentally different kind of
development and yet we often deny
ourselves this
so this gives us a kind of sense we need
to have a better understanding of
architecture now software architecture
is a metaphor
as indeed is technical debt
um every now and then I hear people
trying to debate why it's not a good
metaphor
that's a really dumb debate it's a great
metaphor it's a metaphor that's the
whole point all metaphors are not
supposed to be identities if you're
worried about your brick alignment in
your code you've misunderstood the point
of metaphors the whole point of a
metaphor is to shed light on something
and say I wonder if that applies here is
to provoke questions it's to provoke
thinking if you're going to shut it down
with an argument that it's not exactly
the same thing then you have denied
yourself the opportunity to think
and sometimes when you look at a certain
code base that's what you want
I don't want to have to think about this
but this idea is important because we
often reduce architecture to the
Technologies The Big Box diagrams and
yet we forget the most important thing
about the metaphor architecture is for
people to live in I don't see many
software architecture texts point this
out because it's exactly the same it's
for developers to live in what does that
experience like
now if we're going to talk about
sculpture there is a quote that is um
I've actually put the full attribution
here because it's one of those ones that
does the internet uh does the rounds on
the internet there is a beautiful angel
in that block of marble and I'm going to
find it all I have to do is knock off
the outside pieces of marble and be very
careful not to Chisel into the angel
with my chisel
I've seen this attributed to
Michelangelo
Leonardo da Vinci honestly I swear if
you look in the right corners of the
internet you'll find it attributed to
Abraham Lincoln as well
um
as she is George Pentecost the angel in
the marble early 20th century
there's a thing here
this is a great quote it's quite
inspiring makes you think about things
but we're missing something again
we work with software
first four letters
soft we actually get to Chisel into the
angel and then back out again in fact we
should use a cudlier font there you go
soft
what we often struggle with is the loss
of softness we often treat software as
if it is indeed hard and unforgiving
because actually
one of the coolest things is I've
changed my mind there we go done that's
it you have the ability to do time
travel
which honestly is way cooler than most
other professions
you know from the very humble control Z
I'm just going to undo the Last Action
yeah oh I've spilled my coffee control Z
on reality does not work
I'm perhaps it works in the metaverse
but nobody's been there we don't know
so here's the thing we get to undo
things we actually get to go and say no
let's roll back to the last
good command we get to time travel we
get to move things around we get to
speculate and try things out
we even get to try parallel universes
yeah forget the Multiverse
that's currently popular in SF movies
we've been doing that for decades
software developers got there first time
travel and parallel universes next time
you are introducing yourself to somebody
please keep this in mind don't just say
software developer you're denying
yourself a way cooler job description
but this softness is something that we
lose
so I'm going to take you back to the
late 90s
refactoring by Martin Fowler now this
was a book whose time had very much come
I really first heard the term
refactoring in the context of extreme
programming stream programming
the original XP
and I came around in the mid mid 90s
um
pioneered by Kent back and others
and refactoring was described as a
principal practice
and I remember looking at that going
like yes this is this is what I've been
trying to express and how I've been
thinking about coding for a while in
fact the first company I worked at after
University I didn't have a word for it
I was dealing with a legacy code base
and I just reached for the nearest
mathematical idea which was factor of
factoring or factorization
in fact I'm blessed by the fact that we
have not ended up with refactorization
as a term although I'm sure that there
are corners of the internet that would
prefer that because it sounds more
technical
but that's the key thing is this idea
has been around for a long time but it's
not been articulated as a first class
practice
so that started making it real Martin
Fowler was one of the people on the
original
um C3 XP project with Kent Beck and he
ended up writing this book
refactoring I went to uh see it was
January 1999 and I went to the OIP
conference in Munich and I went to a
one-day workshop with Martin there and
it was just like yes this is exactly
what I've been waiting for it was kind
of a breakdown of like just really
simple structured in terms of kind of
pattern-like thinking
but one of the things that has been most
overlooked
is the subtitle
improving the design of existing code
it's not just saying tidy up your code
make it a bit cleaner he's talking about
something much more fundamental
he's talking about improving the design
it's a yeah and it's it's actually kind
of grasping that and saying this is
possible what is also interesting here
is that this book was written before we
had widespread refactoring tools
although refactoring browsers had
existed up until that point
um they had certainly not gone
mainstream by any stretch of the
imagination and it wasn't really until
the early 2000s that we hit that point
and
Martin gives a definition here what do
we mean by
a refactory
a change made to the internal structure
of software to make it easy to
understand and cheaper to modify without
changing its observable Behavior we'll
come back to what we mean by observable
behavior in a moment there's a subtlety
in there that is often glossed over
but notice to make it easy to understand
and cheaper to modify now what he's not
saying here is take code that sucks and
turn it into code that is good that is
certainly part of this but sometimes we
also take code that was good but the
world has moved on
there's nothing wrong you know we
sometimes it's very easy to look on the
decisions of the past and say ah you
know that's terrible but remember you
know a lot more than you did in the past
that person may have been you that wrote
the code you're in it you have a
privileged position and in the absence
of actually real time travel um you're
not able to take advantage of that and
send them a letter or a missive or you
know do peripheral style kind of
communication back to your former self
or your former colleague and go hey just
try this that's switch statement it's
not going to scale
that switch statement with five cases
is going to become a switch case a
statement with 25 cases and it's going
to be replicated in large parts of your
code
which if you're being paid by the line
of code is magnificent if you're not not
so good
in other words consider something else
maybe polymorphism maybe it's just a
table of callbacks you know use lambdas
the point there is that these are all
possibilities at the time you put in
four or five cases that's entirely
reasonable
okay you don't necessarily know that the
world will move in a particular way
you give it your best shot and then you
come back and many of the things that we
consider to be not good code it's not
that they were not originally good code
but they have grown to be that because
of either their own growth but or the
change in the situation around the code
the world moves on
yeah
code base I dealt with years ago
struggle with the fact that it needed to
move into a multi-threaded world
and it was single threaded no it wasn't
written badly single threaded but it was
its assumptions were everywhere it was
very single threaded
you know the smallest assumption was oh
yeah the world is as we left it the
smallest assumption is that when I do
that and walk away that that
clicker does not move of its own
spontaneous will
okay there is no race condition between
me and somebody else and carefully timed
it so that nobody in the front row could
actually validate that
actually mess that up
the world just changed that's that's
fine so sometimes what we call barcode
is historically good code okay
so
we have this
now
what's interesting is without changing
exactly the same definition
appears in the second edition of
refactoring which came out 20 years
later now the first edition I don't
necessarily recommend getting it it's
it's good for historical reasons uh uses
Java but it's really old Java
uh it's pre-job five for a start
um
and it uses junit but it's really old J
unit we're all junit five now let's
change it three the new book uses types
no actually doesn't use the typescript
it'd be nice to use typescript it uses
JavaScript
um
but this lives in a world where we now
have automated refraction tools so
what's its value well it's still
teaching about design it's still telling
you that if you don't have those
refraction tools understand the steps
that you would take and why
most most of design is why why is it
like this why am I doing this it's the
contemplation of Alternatives and you'll
find that in any set of refactorings
there's contemplation of Alternatives
sometimes you may have extract method
but you also have inline method the
exact opposite
which one is the right one I can't tell
you it's context dependent the idea is
that you're invited to think and figure
out what's what's my code wanted me at
this point what do I know what knowledge
can I bring to bear
it's a design process okay it's this
process just as I said before it's just
like we we like to look at an outcome an
anchor on that in this case I talked
about technical debt and we'd like to
imagine that it's some kind of you know
Pinnacle of clean good code but actually
it's all about process it's all about
what we do on a day-to-day basis now
when it comes to refactoring we need to
understand that there is a flow there is
a process you're always making decisions
and some of these may be supported by
automation
that's your automated refractions but a
lot of them won't be and that's fine
so
let's dig further back in time
this is the early 90s but actually it
all started in the late 80s
this
um refactoring object oriented
Frameworks this is the PHD thesis of
Bill Opdyke who was actually one of the
contributors to the original refactoring
book you can see the date on that is
1992.
and Ralph Johnson is the PHD advisor
Ralph Johnson is one of the gang of four
the following year Ralph Johnson and
Gamma and Helm and vocedes would publish
design patterns but Ralph Johnson's
longer term work was actually
refactoring that was where most of the
early Reef automated refactoring work
was done was at the University of
Urbana-Champaign and a lot of it was
done in small talk except this one the
original
refactoring work from the late 80s to
the early 90s was actually C plus plus
probably the language mainstream
language that's received the least love
from refactoring tools
um and Bill Opti
made the observation said the
refactorings are defined to be Behavior
preserving which kind of makes us think
okay let's go back to this question of
behavior preserving what do we mean by
that
um if you've not had breakfast yet
apologies for this because you probably
think wow yeah look that's that would
look really nice in my stomach
um
however that's that's not the point here
the point is of course I'm going to talk
about Stacks uh the probably the most
overly consumed and over specified uh
data structure um in the history of
software development
um but okay so um I will so let's use
some typescript here I can characterize
it in terms of its depth the top element
um I can pop an element from it I'm
going to keep life simple I'm going to
make it a strict pop we're not getting a
side effect return out of this one I'm
just going to keep life simple and I can
push a new value onto the top now I've
got a different number of different ways
of implementing it I'm going to use an
approach where I bind a Lambda to
um
a variable in fact I'm making it a
function a Constructor function and I
use a local variable to be private
that's the thing about JavaScript and
typescript is that there are many
different object models and some of them
are more or less object-oriented than
others this one is actually the most
perfect object model because it actually
has a true separation between public and
private
um
you can't get your hands on the internal
variables and then I return effectively
a tuple an object that describes the
ways in which I may manipulate and
operate this is the kind of true
interface and it satisfies the interface
we specified before and here is a simple
way of implementing it
um I can do it all just as one line of
forwarding operations okay each one of
these just uses the underlying array and
it wraps it and then conveniently enough
the underlying array has a couple of
extra operations like pot and push that
I can use directly but I can strain it I
give it I now have better names what is
returned is not a thing that you can
manipulate as an array and nor should it
be it is a stack okay I use an array for
implementation there is a strict
separation there
and now I'm going to refactor it in fact
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
effectively upend it reverse it
um
I'm going to change the implementation
I'm going to make instead of the last
element to be the top I'm going to make
the zeroth element B the top
and I'm going to use different primitive
operations on the array to affect that
shift and unshift okay now the point is
from the outside
this looks identical it behaves exactly
the same way that is a refactoring
that's what we mean by Behavior
preserving the idea is that I have not
actually changed the usage if I had
tests
then all of those tests would pass if I
didn't have tests then I'd send myself
on one of my own test driven development
courses because I should have tests for
this so
the point here is that that will satisfy
that but let's understand this idea so
a right-hand rule thing I came up with a
number of years ago I find a very simple
way of trying to understand what are the
qualities and properties of a piece of
code
that are a little richer than we might
normally appreciate
so functional characteristics
operational characteristics
developmental characteristics
we can actually go there are lots of
other subdivisions of this
but the key
thing is that we've got three rather
than two the way that people normally
describe such things as functional and
non-functional
okay which is a
I don't know I don't know how to kind of
approach the whole non-functional thing
because non-functional is
possibly
just the least imaginative
way of describing the things that aren't
functional so I've got these functional
properties and then I've got these other
properties oh what are they well they're
not the functional ones
yeah I've got two kids they're both boys
first one's called Stefan the other one
is not called not Stefan he's got his
own name he's Yannick okay he's his own
person you name positively don't name it
by what it isn't okay
yeah those of you who is if you you know
if you're visiting if you're visiting
London you're thinking yeah I'm gonna go
see some tourist sites I'm going to go
and see you know
Westminster Abbey and then I'm gonna go
and see not West Mr Abby
yeah that's kind of a lot of options
there we need to learn to be specific
and that's what we're supposed to do in
software be specific it's even in the
words like specification first few
letters specific the clue is there
so don't tell me what it isn't tell me
what it is
and also as an assign in English by the
default meaning of non-functional is
broken so if you're having a
conversation with non-developers
just watch out for that okay they're
going to be looking at you guys what do
you mean non-functional requirements I
want it to function what kind of idiot
wants it to break yeah I want it to
crash you know I want it to be like
Azure every Wednesday
um
so
um the point there is it's not just bad
naming it's not just a lack of
imagination it's not just a failure but
to be specific it's the fact that when
we look closer at this category it
reveals itself to be two or at least two
if you want more categories go and look
at ISO 25010
especially of Europe through wake at
three o'clock in the morning
it will send you to sleep but it's a
really good breakdown of eight different
categories of kind of like software
product qualities anyway let's stick
with these three
by functional I mean semantics
it's the stuff I was talking about in
terms of that stack it's the stuff that
we normally think about in terms of user
stories and requirements by operational
it's not what it does it's how it does
it that's time and space okay that's
like how how long does this take that's
our performance characteristics that's
where we care about availability
and things like that that's where a lot
of the abilities that live at runtime
and that's the thing that unifies
that's the thing that unifies um
the uh operational and functional things
they're both runtime qualities
they can be experienced and observed at
runtime okay so a user will experience
those at runtime but they won't
experience the developmental qualities
developmental qualities
are really properties about the
maintainability habitability the degree
to which you've managed the technical
debt the portability of the code the
qualities of the code if you if you have
particular design conventions and
guidelines
for your architecture and detail code
that's where those are followed those
are those are requirements that don't
come from the outside they come from the
team these are what we want from our
code because we live in the architecture
this is how we like to live so that but
this is often neglected sadly that's
also why I put it at the bottom because
everybody kind of sees the first two and
they go yeah whatever
it's at the bottom it doesn't really
matter we can't see it's below a kind of
like imaginary line down the middle of
the screen
so what happens let's let's understand
this is a simple way of classifying the
changes that we make to our code and so
in other words
we probably need a better understanding
of how we change our code how we
interact with our code
off we end up with just like I changed
something many years ago I worked with a
developer who went by the suitably
anonymous name of John Smith
and that was that that was somehow
perfect because
um
his commit messages were also suitably
anonymous
every commit message was pretty much the
same uh changed some code fixed some
bugs added some features
wow thanks John that was that that was
really specific I'm sure the diff will
be very useful to me
um
we can break these things down and
understanding the change that we make if
we have a simple three-axis system oh
it's not perfect but then again my
fingers are not a perfect right angle so
it's good enough but as a simple model
of understanding it's like okay what
have I changed when I add a feature my
goal is to improve or increase
the functionality available
whether that is that an individual
function or a software product level I
am adding something that was not there
before
what happens to the performance
characteristics
maybe they change maybe they stay the
same if they change maybe they get
better maybe they get worse but that's
not our goal our goal is
improve this more semantic capability
likewise the developmental quality
obviously we don't want it to get worse
but that's not our goal our goal is to
add a feature
interestingly enough this looks a lot
like bug fixing
um when you fix a bug when you fix a
defect you're actually the word defect
is surprisingly close to the word
deficit
you are fixing a deficit in other words
we promised you this much functionality
but you got this much that shortfall is
a bug here is the thing that you can't
do that you should be able to do so
although it moves in the same direction
it does so from below the water line
rather than from above it okay so the
movement in that sense is the same but
the sense uh or the meaning of it is
different
but it gets more interesting when we
start looking at things like
optimization
because optimization is resolutely not
about changing the semantics
optimization
because otherwise you know hey I've made
it 10 times faster is not very effective
when you say yes but it's buggy as well
yes but it's a fast bug rather than a
slow bug that's not a virtue
so there is an idea here that it's a
behavior or a functionality preserving
transformation now the problem is I just
slipped into it we have a habit and you
saw it in the bill optike quote and the
Martin Fowler quote of just assuming
that behavior means the semantics it
means the functionality and that somehow
performance is not a behavior Trust Me
performance is absolutely a behavior
um it's just that we have a bias
particularly you know with a shadow of
computer science haunting software
development we have a bias towards
semantics because the other stuff's
really messy but behavior is more than
just the semantics it is
um it's how it does it if something uses
more memory than it should that's a
behavioral problem that you're dealing
with so we need to be a little more
cautious sometimes about how we use the
word Behavior
and we see that our goal is to improve
some aspect of the operational access uh
in truth sometimes something else will
get worse you know we we trade space for
time in many cases I'm going to add a
cash while that trades space for time
um
uh development cruelty maybe it gets
more complex adding a piece of cash into
a piece of code makes it more complex
it's not that it's wrong it's just that
it's going to be more challenging yeah
it's a piece of code you have to deal
with you would not otherwise have had to
deal with
sometimes we discover that the code it
gets simpler um you'd be surprised what
the power of a good Delete can do every
now and then it's just like oh yeah we
got rid of that code and guess what
everything ran faster we'll use less
memory it's like right we chose a
particular data structure and actually
got rid of a whole load of code and we
got better performance as a result
but the reason I want to focus on this
is obviously refraction which is another
Behavior preserving transformation or
functionality preserving transformation
so Behavior preserving is the term that
bill and Martin used but we should be a
little clearer so there's kind of a a
balance here
um and this is where our tooling can
help this is where our tests can help
um in determining that we have respected
that constraint that we haven't broken
with the existing functionality but our
goal is to improve something on
developmental access that is our
explicit goal now you can use these
different dimensions of change as a way
of breaking down your commits you can
say okay I've got a whole load of things
to do let's walk through them okay
here's a bug fix let's not roll the bug
fix now we're going to do the bug fixers
yeah probably let's do the bug fix first
okay
now
performance Improvement
okay let's do that
check that one out
okay now let's take a step back and see
where we are with the code and if
there's anything I can do to improve it
or if there are any insights that I can
get from it that I want to change take
the code in a New Direction maybe it's
just a small tidy but maybe it's
actually a proper design nudge down a
different Fork as it were
so we have the process of refactoring
what does it mean to refactor
to restructure software by applying a
series of refactorings without changing
the observable Behavior semantic
Behavior functional behavior of the
software now
there's a really subtle thing here
that's easy to read past
I'm curiously enough it's probably being
aware of it I read pasta for a number of
years I kind of picked up on it where
the book first came out and then kind of
ignored it whenever I pointed this quote
out to people
a series of refactorings he uses plural
to refactorized you're not just going to
do one thing there's a it's a
progression you're on a journey here
okay so the idea is that refactoring is
a process
and when do we do it well as the author
Annie Dillard observed how we spend our
days is of course how we spend our lives
yeah don't don't make refactoring the
thing you're going to do in the future
oh we'll have a big refactoring sprint
well you know we'll you know our next
major release we'll do it
it's a daily thing it's like you don't
save up well I hope you don't
um personal hygiene until the end of the
month
you know I'm going to save time to yeah
okay so here's a developer approaching
personal hygiene the way that we
approach code you know I'm going to save
time today
I'm going to save time by not brushing
my teeth not having a shower and doing
all those things see how much time I've
saved
then at the end of the month you can I'm
going to spend eight hours
just like you know the whole month
they're gonna go and see people who for
some reason have been avoiding me for
the last month you know I thought that
kind of like you know social distancing
was not the thing anymore but apparently
it is I can't explain why yeah
systems thinking will help you with this
so
let's talk about the automated side of
things
the fact that it is so the fact that we
have relied very much A lot of people
when they arrive into
software development their understanding
of refactoring
is coupled to the idea of automation
it's very difficult to arrive in
software development these days and not
hear refactoring in the context of an
IDE
that's how you will be introduced to it
the focus of this thesis on the is on
the automation uh automating the
refactorings in a way that preserves the
behavior of a program
this was 1992 with the work he began in
the late 80s
so what are the kinds of things that we
might do so here's a book that uh
published
oh the beginning of the last decade
um
97 things every program should know I'm
going to pick an example from downtown
horse North code in the language of the
domain I I like this example for a
number of reasons
um
there's a lot we could be talking about
in terms of the domain understanding
but it's kind of a key point
it's about reflecting on knowledge and
how we learn things and how sometimes we
don't truly appreciate what we know
until we see it reframed in a different
sense so if we look at this
when I look at that and go I have
portfolio IDs by Trader ID don't get
traded it contains key people okay so
this is some Java code and
every single identifier there makes
sense
there's no problem there's the only
abbreviation in there is ID and that's a
real world abbreviation not a developer
abbreviation
strictly speaking there is nothing there
that we can rename
so we might say oh this deserves a
comment or or something like that
but I still don't understand what it
means so maybe that's why I want to
comment alternatively we can realize
actually what we want to do is rename
the whole thing
the scope of renaming is not just an
identifier sometimes what you want is a
name for a bunch of stuff but we tend to
call that extract method
and then suddenly you realize that this
is actually ah trade account view
portfolio Okay if a particular Trader to
prevent Insider dealing
is if they are if they are they have
permissions on portfolio so this is from
an investment Bank
but here all that stuff is now
squirreled away the logic is still there
the mechanics are still there there's
nothing wrong with that description the
mechanics it was just at the wrong level
this is the decision that I'm taking at
this point is Trader can view well
that's cool so interesting enough that
is one of the
most common refractions you're likely to
do extract method so
um last year
I kind of put this online
I tweeted this
and
you know one of the great things about
languages modern IDE support is that
thanks to refactoring tools Legacy code
is a thing of the past and like with all
the languages developers never have to
experience long methods rounding classes
poor identifier names complex logic
honestly for those of you who have
entered software development in the last
two decades I envy you you will never
know the pain of Legacy code you will
never know what people are talking about
when they talk about bad naming or long
methods or rambling classes you will
never experience this
like some people didn't experience the
Tweet after
all the one after that
well here's the point we actually solve
the problem we solved the problem with
Legacy code in the 1990s and rolled it
out in the 2000s here in 2023 we should
have strictly speaking
almost no code that somebody from that
period of time would have called Legacy
but we do
which
tells you it wasn't a problem of
automation at all
it was never a problem with automation
yeah if you don't know what you're going
to do with it it doesn't matter if the
thing I don't know what I want to do
with is automated or not
it turns out that what we needed to
teach and promote was the idea that it's
okay to change the structure and design
of your code as it reflects your
understanding that that is a normal
practice it is not a thing you have to
ask permission for it has a name it's
called software development
if you're a software developer it's
already in your job title you have
permission that's what it's about if you
could transform the daily experience of
yourself and others
from constantly being on the back foot
fighting
fighting the past rather than creating
the future that's kind of yeah that's
kind of a good thing
what we've done is we've removed a large
source of friction and yeah on a routine
basis so let's just align this
linguistically
uh c-sharp 2002. 2001 2002.
there should be no refactoring tools
we're not immediate they followed a
little bit later
Java hit the world in 96
went through a major growth curve
particularly the Enterprise stuff came
along at around the same time as
refactoring tools started being rolled
out in Eclipse IntelliJ and becoming
standard
strictly speaking we live at a point
where there should not be significant
Legacy problems that people are fighting
and yet there are
so
let's try and understand that it wasn't
a tooling issue it was a problem of
understanding and culture and continues
to be
it's nice to have tools
no don't get me wrong on that but that's
not the problem
so
you know in a clearly scientific totally
scientific approach I ask people online
for their opinions
factors do you find you use most whether
automated or not I I was not surprised
by the answers
extract method was one of the most
popular
here's a bunch of stuff I want to give
it a name
extractor
here's the thing with the name I want to
give it a different name
in fact rename is a broad family of
things individual variables all the way
out to interfaces and packages
of course there are boundaries to
renaming we do have to respect that
there's not it's not perfectly fluid
um you know once you hit
once you hit the problem of uh oh
you're using that thing that I gave you
and your code base is not my code base I
don't have and you're actually under a
different project management regime and
in fact you might be in a different
organization it turns out that that that
changes things and I remember a team
struggling with this in the early 2000s
they kept refactoring their interface
names and saying kevla and they
sometimes people ask you questions when
you come in as an outsider they what
their people are looking for is
permission they're looking at well
actually no they're looking for
absolution not permission they are
looking for a blessing
Kathleen we are breaking another team's
code please you know forgive us and tell
us that it's all okay
okay
and that's the problem what they were
doing is on a daily basis they were
changing their mind about some apis and
breaking in other teams build on a
regular basis
yeah it turns out that it's social
engineering you need at this point it
was not a tooling problem okay
sometimes of course there are things
that we find we cannot change
favorite story is clonable
or for those of you watching.net I
clonable
now what is interesting about this is
that that's how you spell it in English
you'll notice that there isn't that
there are that e just disappeared
and obviously a lot of people are going
like yeah but English spelling doesn't
really have a regular system of spelling
you know for those of you who've learned
English as a second or third language it
may well be the language of the worst
and most complicated spelling system
that you have ever learned but let me
tell you let me assure you the problem
is not that English does not have a
regular system of spelling the problem
is that it has about six or seven
regular systems of spelling all at once
that's the problem it's not the absence
of it it's it's got a surplus
you just gotta guess which one are you
feeling lucky and they got it wrong in
fact this is not an remember I said
about knowledge and our ability to
incorporate knowledge as we go
thanks to Twitter I was able to track
this one down because I remember
we're in the mid 90s I remember somebody
pointing this one out
right back before it was released before
Java 1.0.2 which was the first proper
release
back in 19 the beginning of 1996
in fact we just passed the anniversary I
just realized there we go
17th of January was last week
clientable is misspelled with only one e
it's spelled with only one here ask any
Genesis including my wife
ask any English specialist we'll come
back to that such as Henry mcgilton
it's embarrassing let's fix it before we
shift
we can't fix it after and right now very
little code relies upon this typo
now there's a couple of things there you
will notice English is not spelled
correctly
it turns out also I had to check this
one my Gilton is not spelled correctly
either
for those who are interested this is a
known phenomena it's called muffries law
if you write anything correcting or
criticizing the quality of someone else
is editing proofing spelling grammar Etc
there will be some kind of editorial
error in what you have written yeah
anybody experience that one absolutely
yeah
Murphy's Law is specific application of
Murphy's Law right so
that one aside
there's a point there obviously we can't
refactor everything we do have
you know there's a kind of a sense in
our architecture let's go back to that
idea of architecture
architecture is the definite one of the
parts of Architecture is the definition
of structure it's the definition of
boundaries things inside the boundary
are free and easy to change things that
are not so easy to change those are
architectural they are harder to move
um if we I mean
the uh those of you who grapple with the
architecture of this building the Queen
Elizabeth second Center is a
is a labyrinth of complexity and
brutalist architecture
um there are some rooms where you know
so you can actually see it in this room
you see these columns here don't mess
with those they hold the building up
okay everything else everything in space
is free to move this stage is temporary
I can move that freely
the point here is there are some things
you can't change and some things you can
ideally you want to minimize the bits
that you can't change
okay so you want to place your
boundaries and this is something we
learn over time you want to place your
boundaries
to allow freedom on the other side in
other words you can strain your degrees
of freedom on one side say actually
we're going to really it's gonna you're
gonna struggle to change the signatory
of this interface or anything about this
we will have to have a we'll publish a
version in deprecation model
but I can't do that just with a simple
you know flick of a shortcut
but then on the inside I create the
spaces that allow me the freedom on the
inside that's what you're trying to do
maximize the freedom on the other side
of those boundaries that's why we obsess
so much about classes and components and
services and things like that we're
looking for more meaningful boundaries
that allow us
the ease and softness on the inside and
recognize that it's gonna be tougher on
the outside
but I also want to applaud the
achievements of software developers and
software development as an industry
here's wixionry
the entry on clonable notice the
spelling
but notice the Alternative forms
especially in Computing contexts
cloneable with that extra e
we have changed the spelling of a word
through repeated misuse
repetition legitimizes repetition
legitimizes repetition legitimizes
but it also
this is not news
we go back to the late 90s
Martin offers us advice on this don't
publish interfaces prematurely modify
your code ownership policies smooth
refractory
it's talking going about boundaries and
the socio-technical side the
relationship to people that's what you
want to do
you want to get a wave and this is the
interesting thing this runs in the face
of the common commonly communicated
advice of the open closed principle the
idea
that
your classes should be open to extension
and close to modification that's kind of
like that's a practice that is based on
fear it is a principle that is based on
I can't change anything it's actually
the opposite of good practice so if
you're following ocp or you think you're
following ocp according to that don't
prefer good practice instead make code
is open to modification as possible
instead of rolling over and saying ah
can't change it say how do I organize my
structure to allow me to be able to
change it change is not the problem
I want to encourage you I don't want to
push it down I don't want to say you're
not allowed to do that and I'm also not
going to put in all that noise that
encourages extension that kind of like
speculative generality we want to move
in exactly the opposite direction closed
open principle if you want
okay ocp is a failure of good practice
it's a failure of architecture if you're
doing that
so
the other things what are the ones that
are overlooked
extract class so this is interesting
because although rename class and rename
method and all these renames have the
same kind of grouping in people's minds
people are much happier to do extract
methods than extract class and there are
a number of reasons for that sometimes
it's difficult to identify an
abstraction but perhaps take the time if
you've if you've got a class that's
getting too big you know do do start
wondering about it's it's gravitational
attraction you know if your class is
kind of like pulling in all the other
code then you've got a black hole there
and you probably want to do something
about it
so extracting class is massively
underused
extract interface is also not
particularly used
so extraction is not uniformly popular
so let's approach
in lining things the reverse it's a very
useful technique sometimes when you're
trying to make the code move in a
different way sometimes you don't want
to pull everything out you want to put
it all back so you can see what's going
on and then re-partition it reorganize
it it's actually an instinct I found I
run some refactoring workshops and I
always fascinated people immediately
reach for extract method
as one of the first refactorings was
actually it's kind of something you
should do a little bit later in many
cases not all cases it'd be context
sensitive
replace one thing with another one
construct with another
getting rid of stuff is also important
as I observed a few years ago we keep
talking about incremental development we
don't talk enough about decremental
development get rid of stuff okay
streamline the thing okay your knowledge
allows you to say this is dead code
nobody's using this
what's it doing in the code base I've
wasted time and a new code base looking
through something only to be told by
another developer oh don't look at that
we don't use that or why is it in the
code it doesn't cause any harm I've just
spent a day looking at it
you know I mean I don't feel injured by
it but you know time wise we've taken it
here
so let me just give you a very simple
toy example
let's mess about with Roman numerals
because obviously that's something that
everybody does on a daily basis in their
enterprise software
actually it probably would improve a lot
of things to be fair
um but speaking of enterprise software
here is how we might approach this one
so this is Python and this is uh you
can't see everything so let's re resize
there you go
again if you've been paying by the line
of code there is absolutely nothing
wrong with this
but that's the thing about all toy
examples what I love about a lot of
coding Carters is
you people kind of go Ah that's too
simple that's a toy example then you go
straight into the code base they're
working on you go yeah and it's exactly
like the logic that you've got here
okay sometimes you have to kind of look
through this as a lens to see something
else
so this is how to convert
an integer
into Roman numerals
there's nothing wrong with it it works
in that sense if that's our only goal
I don't regard this as particularly good
it's brutally imperative it's
unnecessarily imperative okay this does
not need to be even if you're doing
procedural coding this is Relentless in
a way that I would not expect anyone to
recommend yet curiously
as a collector of old books in software
and I kind of lived through the period
where people recommended Pascal as a
good language because it will teach you
good practice and it's got good language
design and you know what I was foolish
enough to believe people Pascal
is a terrible language it's really badly
designed and it does not promote good
practice in any way it's massively
limited every now and then I will get
somebody
either in person or on Twitter who comes
up to try and correct me of this and
they say oh but I really like Delphi
that's fine but that's not Pascal the
only way that that language was any good
is because they took the original and
said wow this sucks let's add things to
it in other words they made it palatable
it is so limited that you cannot express
well in fact let's just look at the
example
there it is I was leafing through it and
oh Roman numerals done it exactly the
way that I said you shouldn't do it so
let's actually try and amend this now
what a lot of people will do
when looking at this is they will seek
out a pattern now I'm expecting you to
see the detail of this it's
intentionally small enough that only
only people with good eyesight in the
back will be able to see this and I I
don't want you to look at that I want
you to sometimes the trick with code is
to try and take a step back and squinted
it
okay or alternatively just choose a
smaller font what do you see what's the
form of it you can see a lot of
repetition structure
so we're going to refactor this
and we're going to do so in a way that
we don't break it
and in fact here's the tests in fact you
don't even need a testing framework so
this is this is what I used with this
one as a variation what I used so here
is testing without a testing framework
we're going to look at that and we're
going to go what do I see first of all
um and the contrast on that is
absolutely terrible that's a real shame
um yeah contrast is terrible okay
um that you see that's what you get for
having a colorblind guy do the slides
um
so
um what we see is that there are
groupings of four while if if while if
if while if if and then one while left
over
what many people see is this recurring
structure in other words if we reframed
it
while a number is greater than or equal
to 10 something it might be 10 100 1000.
if number is greater than or equal to
nine something it might be 9 90 or 900
and the same for five fifty five hundred
four forty four hundred in other words
there's a repeating structure and then
people will be tempted to extract method
of this repeating structure
premature refactory hold yourself back a
little bit take another look
it turns out in this case if you look at
this and squinted it just right the
thing to remember is that and this is
the whole thing about looking at things
from different points of view and why
refactoring is not just a simple
simple activity in the sense of it
requires a little bit of insight
those ifs
sometimes in the limit and if behaves
just like a while
in the sense that
an if execute zero one times
it's a very limited while
in this particular case because of the
way the values fall you can replace all
of these with while and it still works
which means that you're repeating unit
is in fact this
which leads to a completely different
style of solution
even if you're doing
although this is strongly declarative
it's data driven people don't get taught
about data driven techniques enough
um they don't get taught about as a
first class Paradigm or combining
Paradigm this is very procedural it's
got a procedural for Loop
but this is a technique that I would
expect NEC program at least not I
wouldn't expect a pascal program tonight
if I expect any c programmers to know it
from way back when
but it's also something that is yeah
drop dead easy in pretty much any
language the idea is let's drive it with
data what is the commonality look for
the data structure
now the late Frederick Brooks
made this observation back in the 1970s
representation is the essence of
programming sometimes the Strategic
breakthrough will be a new algorithm
much more often strategic breakthroughs
will come from redoing the
representation all of the data or tables
this is where the heart of the program
lies the idea of try and understand the
structure of the data and then invert
the control with respect to that
was far too often when people refactor
they're just kind of nibbling at the
edges and just taking the surface
phenomena and refactoring those and
tying those up and often bundling them
away into extract method so we can
imagine here
's another little example this is in C
sharp
what I've got here
I go through here I go right I've got a
new list so I've been given some list of
words maybe it's an innumerable maybe
it's actually another list maybe it's an
array I've got a list of words
so I create a copy of that then I sort
it and then I drop in I drop abstraction
level into a bunch of mechanics
okay it's just like there's a there's a
real there's a real change here this
idea that you should try and work at the
same level of abstraction if you
suddenly find yourself dropping into
mechanics it doesn't mean you don't want
the mechanics it just means you need to
kind of think well hang on I said the
first thing I said was take a copy then
I said sort it and now I say what set up
a variable assign it to null okay you're
the wrong level here
and there's a whole load of horsing
around
which is ultimately
about removing duplicates
so let's call it that
remove duplicates so this is C Sharp I
can make it an extension method and
confuse all my colleagues
we can improve on the naming because
it's not really about removing
duplicates it's about removing adjacent
tube because that's the more honest one
the precondition is that it must be
sorted to remove all duplicates
but actually it's just about removing
adjacent duplicates
and for a lot of people they go huh
yeah we're done we've improved it
some people will then say
stand back I know link
oh no I'd ask you to stand back
that's not a big Improvement I'm afraid
um
I know the repetition legitimizes but if
you've got the same variable occurring
three times in a single expression
you've got to say that's a smell
a better use of Link would not to be
used to use the keywords and would be
this form
and we might might Pat ourselves on the
back say we are done
but then
I hear the words of the late Fred Brooks
representation is the essence of
programming huh oh yeah
that's what I wanted
what I wanted was
basically a collection of unique words
in sorted order
and what I've done is and what's funny
is that people often say oh yeah you're
using functional thinking here yeah look
at me using data structures
so
the whole point is this is the most
declarative of all of them I've just
said what I want I'm not telling you how
to do it I'm not giving you a process
this is
that
so sometimes refactoring will take us
down some
surprising Avenues some different
insights and it's a reminder dijkstra
observed back in 72 the purpose of
abstraction is not to be vague we often
associate abstract and abstraction
sometimes with being vague which
actually is this Precision to create a
new semantic level in which one can be
absolutely precise it's to be specific
this is what I really mean I want to
tell you if I've got something there
that does exactly what I need
I might not realize that and importantly
that progression I just showed you is
not a is not to diss anybody forever
having this code or go through those
steps sometimes those steps are
necessary intermediates until something
becomes so obvious you go ah
wow why did I not see this before you
couldn't have seen it before you were
locked into a different mindset
refactoring is getting your hands dirty
in the codes playing with the clay okay
it's actually reshaping it go oh now I
understand you thought you understood
when you started but only when you start
manipulating it he's like oh now I'm
best about with it six ways to Sunday
I can now figure out the seventh way
so final piece I'll look at
um another one from 97 things to show
you kind of a radical reframing one I've
used a number of times one of my
favorite pieces from that book by uh
Burke hoffnerville although I'm not
supposed to say as the editor I have
favorite pieces um put the mouse down
step away from the keyboard first of all
great title
it tells you exactly how to deal with
most problems you get so entrenched at
the level at which you found the problem
you try everything and exhaust that
level and the only thing apparently left
you is to invest more time
and what you do is you push harder at
the thing that's not working for you
you're stuck at that level
take step back
do something in fact I often tell people
whatever it is that you're not doing try
that
as in if you are currently sitting try
standing if you are currently standing
try sitting if you are listening to
music turn the music off if you're not
listening to music Turn some music on
yeah
if I'm messing about with code or
working typically I will listen to
ambient music
[Music]
um
uh or I'll listen just sort of uh sort
of rainforest or ocean sounds
if I'm stuck with something sometimes I
turn that off
or alternatively I put on some
progressive metal
you just need to get your mind because
clearly wherever you are is not helping
you you need to move somewhere else
if you've been drinking caffeine all
morning
guess what herbal tea is a really good
break from that if you're saying ah I'm
virtuous I don't drink caffeine try it
try it come to the dark side
but that's the thing it'll change the
way you think
go for a walk have a chat with somebody
yeah don't don't try and ring up
somebody that you currently have a
grievance with like your you know uh
like a provider yeah yeah no no you did
say that we'd be reconnected by Tuesday
that's just going to get you angry
but do something else
why because it gives you a different
Insight it refreshes things you take you
save time by doing something else rather
than investing on that kind of problem
so here is a piece of code that um
Burke was looking at in fact this is not
the piece of code book was looking at
this is the piece that after he
refactored it the first time
so it must have been quite frightening
the first time
he took some code he said okay let's
cook it down and that's the important
thing a lot of people stop here they do
the kind of the cooking down they kind
of a little bit extract meth a little
bit of tidying up the logic a few
renames and a bit of movement
but they haven't actually challenged or
the the the the Assumption of where the
code is and sometimes you can't do that
immediately that's fine
but that's why he you know put the mouse
down and stepped away from the keyboard
but you can see there's a lot going on
here and in fact you know the the thing
I want to point out is there's a dot dot
dot here there's a lot more of this
stuff this is relentlessly imperative
we're trying to parse a string to see if
it contains a valid 12-hour time it's a
brutal way of doing it
so anyway he steps away from the
keyboard
I suddenly realized wait a minute
this is a pack magic problem
why am I why am I doing all of this this
is a really painful way to do it again I
refer you to large amounts of code in
the world
now of course there is the idea that
sometimes people say you know I had a
problem I solved it with a reg X now I
have two problems or Star problems if
you're being incredibly accurate
but sometimes it's just the right thing
and what's great is if you even if you
don't know reg X's it's really easy to
explain
so I can take my younger son he's 17.
you know as python
I can walk him through this Java
he will have lost interest before we
reach the dot dot dot
just what do you think what's the
explanation sound like
he's seen exceptions before all this
kind of stuff in fact probably you say
Dad why didn't they do it in Python and
I'll say son I don't know python solves
surprising number of problems it's not
perfect but when it comes to string
manipulation Java is one of the most
painful ways of doing it
um it's like putting needles in your
eyes just not as much fun
um
but here I don't think my son knows reg
axes
but I can walk left to right
I'm trying to find out where this string
matches oh well there we go immediately
a grouping of zero followed by one to
nine or one followed by zero to two and
then account because then height zero
followed by zero to five
and then zero to nine fight okay
um
repetition legitimizes
now
the point here is I've just read that
left or right that's the property of
declarative code in many forms of
declarative code
showing the data structure you just
literally described the shape of the
problem then all you need is a little
icing a for Loop or an appropriate
method and that does the thing this is
the kind of thing that we need to be
encouraging ourselves but notice there
is no name to refactoring for this
I've changed the design by having to
I've jostled the existing design around
probably through automation
automated refactorings I've jostled it
around and then eventually
break now
so that brings us onto the home straight
and the need for coffee because I
realize I have overrun by five minutes
I took you back in time let's take you
back further let's go back to the 19th
century this is Isabella Beaton who died
sadly very young not even 30 I don't
think but um she wrote a series of
columns
um
on household management that got
collected into a book and her Mrs
beaton's book and Mrs beaton's cookery
book were actually kind of they survived
well into the 20th century as a kind of
a byword for how to think about you know
actually
the engineering and the engineering of
the processes of your of your home
um but when it came to kitchens it turns
out that she was an early adopter of
refactoring
there is no work like early work
how we live our lives is of course how
we spend our days
clear as you go model makes more model
yeah she was talking about code
but Babbage had not yet invented the
Difference Engine so she was forced to
talk about kitchens instead
not to wash plates and dishes soon after
using makes more work yeah see the word
see it's all about refactoring cleverly
coded
but also if we relate the activity of
writing code to the active other
activities of writing
Ernest Hemingway left us with the
simplest advice the only kind of writing
is rewriting
thank you very much
okay I don't have any time for questions
so I could have the mic up okay I don't
have any time for questions or other I
do but well let's take those offline I'm
around for coffee and all the rest of
the day but yeah have a good rest of day